[Musique]
première année j'avais aucune idée de ce
qu'était l'entrepreneuriat
en route je savais que une des forces
d'une école de commerce c'est la
puissance de son réseau c'est le réseau
que l'on peut se créer
et donc dès la première année j'en ai
profité pour rejoindre une équipe
sportive qui m'a permis de rejoindre une
association puis une deuxième d'une
troisième d'une quatrième jusqu'à ce que
je devienne un véritable monstre de la
société
et en fait
plus sérieusement tous ces expériences
m'ont permis de rencontrer des personnes
inspirantes qui m'ont poussé à devenir
le meilleur de moi-même
en deuxième année j'y connaissais
toujours rien entrepreneuriat mais avec
trois amis on s'est lancé on a créé
notre premier entreprise
et
donc à ce moment là je me disais que
tout allait très vite c'était génial en
fait on découvrait plein de choses tout
allait très vite donc l'année d'après le
projet commençait à s'intensifier donc
le rythme s'accélérer les projets
s'accumulaient et en fait j'avais
l'impression que petit à petit le lien
entre ma vie perso et mon entreprise se
rapprocher donc j'avais l'impression de
passer à côté de certaines choses de
devoir dire non plus souvent de
d'être frustré de pas pouvoir faire tout
ce que j'avais envie de faire et donc je
me suis posé la question est-ce vraiment
possible d'entreprendre sans rater sa
vie
je vous partage ici mais deux cascades
préférées
la première ma casquette d'étudiant que
je mets pour aller en cours que je mets
pour aller aux After Work pour sortir
avec mes amis
pour réviser un petit peu aux exams et
de l'autre côté ma casquette
d'entrepreneur que je mets pour signer
mes contrats pour aller déjeuner avec
mes clients pour aller travailler au
bureau
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
porter ces deux casquettes c'était pas
toujours facile parce qu'on était sans
cesse en train de penser à plein de
choses on passait d'une activité à une
autre et donc petit à petit quand les
semaines que les semaines intenses
s'accumulaient et j'avais l'impression
de d'avoir la tête en l'air et de plus
savoir à quoi penser et donc
à ce moment là je me suis dit
je me suis dit mais
comment est-ce que je vais faire pour
pour trouver cet équilibre trouver cet
écrivain entre entre ma vie et moi celle
que j'avais avant et peut-être celle que
je veux avoir maintenant celle là où je
vais arriver
donc je vais vous partager trois points
qui m'ont beaucoup aidé
pour pour moi aujourd'hui de venir et me
rapprocher de l'équilibre entre cette
vie perso et
cette vie d'entrepreneur mais avant ça
j'ai découvert plusieurs risques
aujourd'hui donc des statistiques assez
folles combien d'entre vous ont déjà
pris le prennent le métro tous les jours
ici
combien d'entre vous ont déjà loupé
votre votre station de métro parce que
vous pensez à autre chose ou c'est pas
concentré
voilà alors moi avant d'avoir ces deux
casquettes ça m'arrivait jamais
maintenant ça m'arrive tout le temps
et donc je me suis dit donc je suis allé
faire quelques études je suis allé
regarder un peu l'entrepreneur dans sa
globalité et j'ai découvert quelques
statistiques assez folles donc d'après
l'Insee les startups qui se lancent
échouent à 80%
je l'ai creuser un peu plus et j'ai vu
que d'après Michael Freeman un
professeur université de Californie
donc le pourcentage d'entrepreneurs qui
qui se lancent et qui ont des
comment dire des qui ont des troubles de
des troubles dépressifs c'est plus de
50%. donc ça allait encore plus loin que
ça parce que il y a deux fois plus
d'entrepreneurs qui ont des troubles
dépressifs trois fois plus de risques de
tomber dans tomber en dépression tomber
dans les addictions 6 fois plus de
risques de 6 fois plus de risques de
d'avoir des troubles de l'attention et
dix fois plus de risques d'être d'avoir
des troubles bipolaires
tout ça pour dire que ces chiffres font
très peur et contrairement à ce qu'on
voit sur sur Linkedin en fait on n'est
pas habitué à voir à voir ces chiffres
là ce qu'on voit sur sur Linkedin
généralement c'est l'entrepreneur à
succès qui a fait des centaines de
milliers d'euros en travaillant 4 heures
par jour c'est le père de famille le
père de 6 enfants qui a la fois
entrepreneur sérieux sur-entrepreneur
#invester qu'est-ce qu'il y a dehors à
ses heures perdues mais il faut faire
attention à tout ça et je pense que les
réseaux sociaux c'est il y a beaucoup de
bonnes choses mais parfois faut savoir
les mettre de côté dans la vraie vie
heureusement il y a des solutions qui
permettent de pas tomber dans ces
extrêmes là donc je vais revenir à mes
trois conseils en tout cas trois choses
qui m'ont aidé moi à me rapprocher de
cet équilibre entre ma vie perso et mon
entreprise
alors le premier s'organiser alors là
vous allez me dire merci Simon merci
j'ai payé 20 euros pour pour venir ce
soir pour que tu me dis qu'il faut que
je m'organise mieux alors oui c'est vrai
que depuis tout petit on nous répète à
l'école qu'il faut qu'il faut mieux
s'organiser pour pour faire ses devoirs
pour travailler pour avoir du temps à
côté
mais j'essaie d'aller un peu plus loin
et de creuser un peu plus
donc c'est vrai que l'organisation il
n'y a pas de règle universelle c'est
quelque chose que
faut trouver sa méthode à soi et pour
revenir quelques années avant quand je
le révisais pour le bac tous les soirs
je préparé sur une feuille blanche je
fais des plages horaires par matière sur
ce que j'allais réviser ou travailler ce
qui fait que le lendemain je savais
exactement ce sur quoi je devais
travailler donc aujourd'hui j'ai décidé
d'appliquer cette méthode dans ma vie
dans ma vie pro pour planifier mes
semaines à l'avance donc le dimanche
soir je
bloque des créneaux sur mon agenda en
fonction des tâches que j'ai effectuées
dans la semaine ce qui fait que la
semaine simplement je laisse couler et
j'ai juste à me laisser porter par mon
agenda le but maintenant le but du jeu
c'est de le respecter le plus possible
la deuxième chose que je voulais vous
partager c'est le fait de bien
s'entourer nous sommes la moyenne des 5
personnes qui nous fréquentons le plus
souvent
autant les choisir donc
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui notre
environnement influe énormément sur nos
capacités et nos performances vous
connaissez peut-être la métaphore de la
bouteille d'eau donc cette bouteille
d'eau dans un supermarché elle vaut
environ 50 centimes dans un bar elle
peut valoir environ 2 euros dans un bon
restaurant dans un hôtel c'est pas
monter jusqu'à 5 euros dans un aéroport
parce qu'il y a 10 euros pourtant le la
marque la quantité de cette bouteille
d'eau reste identique la seule chose qui
va changer c'est le lieu
en fait l'idée ici c'est de montrer que
ce qui va influencer notre valeur ça va
être le lieu dans lequel on se trouve
donc c'est pareil dans la vraie vie
parfois on remarque qu'on sent pas au
bon endroit qu'on n'est pas qu'on n'est
pas assez valorisé c'était parce qu'on
n'est pas au bon endroit ou pas avec les
bonnes personnes donc c'est hyper
important de de bien s'entourer et de
communiquer avec les personnes qui nous
entourent
le troisième point ça va être de passer
à l'action aujourd'hui on est dans un
monde où on consomme énormément de
contenu donc avec les réseaux sociaux
YouTube Instagram LinkedIn notre cerveau
il est absorbé par par tout le contenu
de ces réseaux donc l'élément
différenciant ça va être vraiment de
passer à l'action en fait cette petite
action qui fait que derrière il y en
aura une deuxième une troisième une
quatrième
malgré tout ça j'ai beaucoup de
personnes qui viennent me voir et qui me
disent l'entrepreneur ça m'intéresse
j'ai plein d'idées d'ailleurs ce
confidentiel je t'en parle pas mais
peut-être que je me lancerai plus tard
quand j'aurai un peu plus d'expérience
quand je construis un réseau quand je
j'aurai les fonds pour lancer mais
pourquoi pas maintenant
parce que ce sera peut-être jamais
finalement
je pense que quand on est jeune et quand
on est étudiant on a très peu de risques
en fait c'est l'opportunité parfaite
pour pour oser pour pour tester des
choses pour pour échouer pour pour
recommencer
moi ce qui me motive le plus dans
l'entrepreneuriat c'est le fait de se
dépasser le fait de en fait arriver un
moment où on pensait que c'était
impossible et on y croyant en y allant à
fond on a réussi
si on m'avait dit par exemple il y a
quelques années que qui a 20 ans je
serai là ce soir pour vous donner une
conférence TEDx je voudrais jamais cru
pareil je vous aurais jamais cru si vous
m'aviez dit que je donnerais des cours
en école de commerce où je vous aurais
jamais cru si vous m'aviez dit que je
formerai des des managers de de grands
groupes français voilà
en fait entreprendre c'est la liberté de
réaliser ses propres projets je suis pas
certain qu'aujourd'hui tous les
étudiants en école soient passionnés par
ce qu'ils vont en cours
entrepôtres c'est justement la capacité
de d'aller suivre sa passion ce qui nous
anime et de et de et d'aller encore plus
loin de d'apprendre de mettre en
pratique ce qu'on apprend en cours
pour créer quelque chose qui nous
passionne
l'entrepreneuriat c'est aussi
l'opportunité de
créer quelque chose d'innovant de
disrupter un marché ou un concept c'est
aussi l'opportunité de créer quelque
chose de plus grand que nous
crée quelque chose de plus grand que
nous en gardant en tête que entreprendre
c'est pas seulement entreprendre un
projet mais c'est entreprendre sa vie
qu'une entrepreneuriat c'est un marathon
un marathon qui mérite d'être vécu
et plutôt que de se concentrer sur les
préparations le départ ou l'arrivée
profitons de chacune des étapes
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]